I'm super excited to be sitting here
with Daniel schloss a hilarious comedian
scotsman Scott derogatory no Ascot loss
doesn't sound good it sounds like a side
like a side dish I'll have the the
turkey burger gifts Ross if it been a
girl way that managed well I can I can
we can choose we can make we make a
fresh in the back nobody likes to Dale's
loss it's not great you're a young man
how old are you I'm 23 and you've been
doing comedy six now that's a long time
yeah so your parents who encourage you
to go into comedy oh yeah then what do
they do uh my mom is she's a PhD in
microbiology so it's like greenhouse
emissions oh uh my dad is a computer
programmer who's kind of working on 3d
underwater sonar so they're both
geniuses genius it man this is what
happened when you combine their sperm no
that's not break see work so did your
mother's firm my dad's no okay when the
true sperms give mine they make a child
so stupid it thinks both people have
screwed oh it's the missus firmly yeah
yeah ovum oh oh be a bit of an over
minute
well I didn't know for years and years I
thought the I thought the sperm was the
baby and the egg was it's the house oh
it's this house yeah cuz he just goes in
there and the egg keeps it safe yeah man
it grows into a baby I actually think
that informs how we view men and women
it's such a male perspective it's like
the sperm is to do late
do you stay she looked after my mom
under it you ran can you teach me good
Scottish good but I think we could good
good do how about here we have designer
bags announcer you can get a fake good
Gucci couch couch is them the bit
between your balls we call that the
taint all the tabling bridges between
our divisions call that the danger the
not check is it's not cheap anus nice
and let's know what I'm calling it
that's amazing not you
what about intercourse you having
intercourse I have had sex with over one
woman so let's doubled it I'm gonna call
that double digits cuz I does I go to it
oh so double digits of course [ __ ] it's
like home digits for years and years
like all my comedian friends always had
sort of like great sag stories Mika's
comedians do and it wasn't till I went
to Sweden for the party you went to
Sweden I went to sweet nightmare this
girl that let me gets here 24 and you
got like a three year relationship
recently she's like I might with two
kids I was like oh well okay well that's
just in the game over sign came to yeah
but I'm not an [ __ ] I'll play after
the credits and stuff I wasn't gonna
stop talking to her yeah yeah she wasn't
mad like the DMV is under stress yeah
I've been so I'm like I'm gonna go to
that party she's like oh I thought I
thought we were gonna go back to your
hotel room and I'm sex I know that oh I
didn't I don't know that was an option
but sure that's his way better than why
I planned so like you your husband are
divorced
she's like no but he cheated on me three
years ago so I own one she kissed me
when she kissed me I know it's her hat
was on one of her husband but her other
hand wasn't anywhere and she brought it
up here and took a fall or buts kissing
and then saying it to her husband and I
was like okay so this is like a
Sweden's a very liberal place it's very
proof or proof thinking and stuff so
this is like an agreement
you guys have she said no I just want to
see you'll react
having sex wait in the white I don't
have a choice to anymore in this and I
was drunk you're just a pawn diode I was
used oh so good did you lose amazing so
your morning uh her phone's going off
the entire time
Jesus wife text no phone snapchats no
and I'm like what did the snap get him
like videos are very good and so I'm
like you're gonna need to hang that up
this fridge me turn off like this
distract me she leaned over answered it
put her on loudspeaker and then started
morning down the phone to her husband
who was screaming [ __ ] in Swedish back
at me which I didn't understand that it
almost definitely wasn't encouragement
I've uh been unable to perform because
the mood wasn't right
you're still boning a woman while her
husband's screaming at both of you in a
goofy sounding language yeah Daniel I've
never met you before this is a real
pleasure i watch your stuff on Conan
you're super funny love to have you on
this show some time as a stand-up as
well
definitely thank you for doing this
thank you very much for having me Daniel
floss everybody it's a cider sauce and
always do it